de acuerdo al informe de wwf planeta
vivo de 2020 se registró que desde 1970
una caída del 68 por ciento de la
biodiversidad a nivel mundial que
propuestas urgentes se tiene la onu para
cambiar esa tendencia
angela es un gran gusto compartir con
ustedes este momento y celebrar con
ustedes una una llamada internacional de
la biodiversidad como usted lo menciona
todos los estudios que se han realizado
actualmente demuestran que hay un
declive global de la diversidad
biológica es un declive tremendamente
preocupante en américa latina y el
caribe es cerca del 94% de las especies
que han sido evaluadas están perdiendo
sus poblaciones y por lo tanto se
requieren unas medidas urgentes este es
un año muy importante porque se está
negociando el nuevo marco global de
biodiversidad por parte de todas las
naciones es una negociación que ocurrirá
a finales de este año y allí se está
planteando un nivel de ambición sin
precedentes para detener la pérdida de
biodiversidad en todo el mundo
principalmente necesitamos no solamente
incrementar nuestros esfuerzos para
observar la biodiversidad que aún existe
en el planeta y también para iniciar las
acciones de restauración sino también
para transformar los sistemas
productivos en todo el mundo incluyendo
y sobre todo los sistemas
agroalimentarios pero también
necesitamos transformaciones en los
sistemas de infraestructura a nivel
planetario en los sistemas energéticos
todo esto son medidas y de acuerdo con
el foro mundial económico generarían
unos 390 millones de nuevos empleos de
aquí al 2030 y generarían
aproximadamente unos 10 trillones de
dólares americanos nuevos negocios a
nivel mundial esto quiere decir que hay
una gran oportunidad para hacer esas
transformaciones mire le quiero
preguntar por otro tema que nos toca a
todos y es que a partir de la irrupción
de kobe 19 se advirtió que la pérdida de
biodiversidad podría suponer un aumento
de este tipo de virus en el futuro cuál
es la correlación que existe ahí
bueno definitivamente hay una
correlación con la pérdida de
biodiversidad y lo que se llaman las
enfermedades zoonóticas y también las
enfermedades emergentes como el kobe 19
y el 70% de todas las enfermedades
zoonóticas que se están descubriendo en
el mundo son derivadas de la degradación
de los ecosistemas por lo tanto estamos
expuestos a nuevas pandemias como la del
cobi 19 y es algo tremendamente
preocupante porque no sabemos qué podría
suceder frente a algo que sucediera en
otro punto del mundo por lo tanto
precisamente proteger la diversidad
biológica es la ruta y en ese sentido
quisiera señalar la que los ministros y
ministras de ambiente de américa latina
y el caribe adoptaron en este febrero
una decisión precisamente para conservar
la biodiversidad con el fin de prevenir
futuras pandemias y recuperarse de los
impactos económicos y sociales que nos
está dejando esta